so we began the show yesterday talking
about the homelessness crisis the uh
vagrancy crisis more like it um and
which is which is by the way the and I
need to be better about this too but
this is the word we should be using
vagrant um which is the word we used to
use for what we now call homeless people
but in fact this is vagrancy these are
vagrants and we talked about this CR
especially in places like San Francisco
but in San Francisco as we discussed
they magically found a way to solve the
problem for a few days anyway as they
prepare for a visit from various
political leaders and CEOs and you know
the the Communist head of China um well
yesterday Gavin Nome addressed this
issue and was well shockingly honest
let's
listen I know folks say oh they're just
cleaning up this place cuz all those
fancy leaders are coming into town um
that's
true because it's
true but it's also true for months and
months and months prior to Apec we've
been having different
conversations okay it's true and it's
true because it's true I guess that is
also
true um but you know it's it's it's okay
though he says because yeah we solved
this problem we cleaned up the streets
uh because of all these uh fancy rich
people are coming into town uh but but
you know that doesn't mean that we don't
care about everybody else because we
were having
conversations so when it comes to
cleaning up the street and cleaning the
city up for your citizens the people who
live there every day well when it comes
to that you'll have
conversations oh we'll have a lot of
conversations we'll engage in all kinds
of discussions and conversations and
meetings and hearings and
everything but when it comes to like
these rich people coming into town uh
well well for that we're there's no
conversation we're just going to get it
done now um meanwhile while we're on
this subject here's something that is
likely related to it daily wire reports
California Democratic governor Gavin
Nome declared a state of emergency over
the weekend after a massive fire erupted
at a homeless encampment beneath a major
freeway near downtown Los Angeles
closing the thorough fars now
compromised structure indefinitely and
impacting hundreds of thousands of
commuters the state quote from a press
release from Newsome the state is
mobilizing resources and taking steps to
ensure any necessary repairs are
completed as soon as possible to
minimize the impact on those traveling
in and around Los Angeles according to
the Los Angeles Fire Department The
Blaze started around 12:30 a.m. on
Saturday under Interstate 10 and quickly
spread to a storage facility filled with
pallets trailers and vehicles with said
the Flames engulfed both sides of the
14th Street underneath the portion of
the freeway melted steel guard rails and
damaged a number of fire trucks
um and uh many people have speculated uh
David Ortiz public information officer
for lafd reportedly said a large
homeless encampment with tents and RVs
dwell underneath the freeway where the
fire started so of course many people
have uh I
think reasonably speculated that the uh
homeless encampment is what started this
fire now it has been declared since then
that the fire was set deliberately that
this was a deliberate Act of arson and
maybe it was um I think it's more likely
that it was a deliberate fire but not
necessarily arson because you've got a
refugee camp of vagrants under that
bridge and they've got you know propane
tanks and and they're starting fires and
their makeshift kitchens and so on and
so it still seems most likely that this
this fire was originated from it's a
deliberate fire because they're cooking
they whatever they're eating and um and
then it spread from there and of course
if that's the case then they'll never
tell us because the last thing Nome
needs right now is a major highway shut
down because of a bridge getting set on
fire from the outof control vagrants
that are all over his State politically
that's not what he wants or needs which
is why if that's what happened we'll
never be we'll never get the full story
or the true story either way the fact
remains that the homeless problem is a
crisis and this is why vagrancy should
be
illegal like it should not be a legal
option to set up an encampment under a
bridge or on a
sidewalk um it it's actually it's crazy
that this is even allowed it should not
be allowed it should be against the
law you know I said this
um which is why in in most cases you
know if you want to if you have a tent
and you want to set up your tent
somewhere and you're not a vagrant
there's all kinds of laws and
regulations and there's only certain
places you can go with your tent and set
it up and uh you got to get permits and
you got to do everything sometimes you
got to pay to access a campground and
all these kinds of things so in in most
cases we all understand that you can't
just like take a tent and set it up
anywhere you want especially not in a
public area people are trying to walk by
you can't do
that yeah we've carved out this
exception for um for V
fragrants um and you know I said this
yesterday on on uh on Twitter when
someone
um you know I said this this should be
illegal and someone asked me as they
often do well well what are the homeless
people supposed to do if vagrancy is
illegal you know what where are they
supposed to go what are they supposed to
do and my answer was simple my answer to
most things are simple because as you
know I'm a simple man and I see Simple
Solutions to problems that most people
seem to think are
complicated and I think most problems
actually are not all that complicated
that doesn't mean that most solutions
are
easy it's there's a difference between
simple and easy but most solutions to
most problems are
simple and um and so you know I asked
this question I said well one thing
homeless people can do is they can stop
doing drugs and they can get a job those
are the first two steps that I would
personally explore and this of course
provoked a lot of outrage on social
media how dare I suggest such a thing
how dare I suggest that it'd be better
to not dedicate your entire life to
Fentanyl and heroin you know how dare I
suggest that it's it's it's a outrageous
thing to say the October 15th tax
deadline has coming onone I know many of
you might be ding the stress of filing
your taxes filing your taxes can be a
long excruciating process but if you
fail to file you'll start to pile
penalties onto your tax debt that's why
you need to check out tax Network USA
the team of tax Network USA has a track
record of success they've reduced tax
debt for numerous clients totaling over
$1 billion whether you're looking at a
$10,000 a $1 million tax debt they can
help you win uh with a settlement
doesn't matter if you haven't filed in
one year five years even a Whole Decade
tax Network USA is equipped to secure
the best settlement for you the expert
attorneys and tax professionals at tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no matter how they started don't
let tax debt control your life any
longer take the first step toward
resolving your tax issues by by visiting
tax Network usa.com Walsh that's tax
Network
usa.com Walsh today uh lots of comments
like that reading just a few of
them uh someone says all the homeless
are doing drugs what an effing
stereotypic
racist someone else says as a recovering
addict shut the f
up uh someone else said I know people
who don't do drugs and have been
actively applying for months and still
nothing I think the first step would be
to address what's causing people to do
drugs and what's causing people to not
work um and someone else is that if you
never did drugs and have a job what then
anyway you get the idea
um first of all and this we have to
continue to to establish this that the
number of of sober homeless
people who either have jobs or are
actively applying and trying to get one
that number it's probably like five in
the whole country if that many okay it's
like a non-existent population of sober
homeless people who are really like
trying to get a job and it's just and
they're down on the luck and it's not
working out it's like
it's you have probably never in your
life walk past the homeless person that
would fall into that
category um if you are a sober sane
person there is no legitimate reason why
you should be living under a bridge or
on a tent on the sidewalk it is actually
very easy to get a job it is very easy
to afford some kind of housing may not
be a very good job I didn't say it's
easy to get a good job may not be very
nice housing but a sober sane person can
find something pretty easily right like
whoever you are watching this you could
go out right now and you could get 15
jobs in in a day I mean you could easily
you get 15
jobs again they might not be great jobs
but you can get
them and if you're starting from nothing
now and there are people it's not that
simple like if you have a family and and
uh six kids you know myself I got a
mortgage I if I lose my job tomorrow
it's not like going to McDonald's is not
going to help me because it's not g to
do go it's not GNA get even close to
paying for everything I need to pay for
right so it's not quite that simple I
can just go out and apply for a job and
take anything it's it's it's more
complicated if you're on the sidewalk
though if you're living on the sidewalk
and if you have
nothing then anything is better than
nothing and so working at McDonald's and
living in a crappy studio apartment is a
huge step up and there's no reason to
not take
it it it's a
solution the fact that the solution is
so easy and accessible proves that the
homeless for the most part are not
normal people just down on their luck
that's not the case for the vast
majority of instances so if getting a
job is not an
option right if if if if you're dealing
with home most people and and I say well
why why can't they just get a job you
say well they can't
okay well that tells us that these
people these are people who are mentally
incapacitated either because they're
insane or because drugs have fried their
brains and that that is true like that
category definitely exists that's
probably most of them a great many of
these people it's true for a great many
of these people even getting a job at
McDonald's is basically out of the
question they are not fit even to work
at McDonald's which also means
obviously that quote unquote affordable
housing is not a solution simply giving
them
shelter and housing is not a solution
these are people that even according to
the people that disagree with me these
are people who they're unfit to work at
McDonald's they can't even do
that so you put them in Free Housing and
they'll be back on the street in 5
minutes that's the reality which is why
the the the Third step in the solution
goes back to what we talked about in the
opening which is
institutions
asylums okay here's what it comes down
to go to any homeless encampment
anywhere in the
country if there's anyone in that
encampment who is capable of working at
McDonald's then they should be required
to do that go get a
job get off the street that's the
message anyone in that category go do
that
anyone who can't do that needs to be
institutionalized immediately round it
up and put in an institution put in an
asylum for people who are not mentally
fit for
society that's how you solve the problem
okay you round them up and you put them
in institutions put them in asylums all
of
them and we can either
because that's it that's it's these
people exist and so they can either be
in asylums which is what we used to do
or they can be on the street those are
the only two options again going back to
the beginning you know we're dealing
with a lot it's like when when you're
dealing with a difficult though not
complicated when you're dealing with a
difficult
problem many times there there's there's
the choices are not
good like there is no choice where
everything is great and there are roses
growing everything and unicorns are
flying in the sky that that choice isn't
on the
table and so when it comes to the
homeless problem there's really two
options they can be on the street all
over the street all over our cities
setting bridges on fire and taking dumps
on the sidewalk or they can be in an
institution somewhere period those are
the two options it's got to be one or
the other and if you're saying well we
don't want to round them up put them in
Asylum it's a horrible thing to say okay
then what you are saying is you'd rather
have them on the street and don't tell
me that no no I want a third option
there is no third option you it
doesn't exist so I don't want to hear
about your third option round them up
put them in asylums or you leave them on
the street that's it which one you only
get two we used to put them in asylums
that's why we didn't have homeless all
over the street now we don't have
asylums anymore and they're all over the
street it's not hard it's not hard to
connect the dots here that the
mathematical equation is is not a is
it's one that even I can
solve so that's it that's what it comes
down to hey YouTube thanks for listening
to the show if you'd like access to my
full show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there